- [Mark] All right, Ed,
Ed, where are you from,
where'd you grow up?
- [Ed] In New York.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family,
you had both of your parents growing up?
- [Ed] Yes.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- [Ed] Good.
- [Mark] No abuse, nothing?
- No.
- [Mark] Nothing crazy.
- No abuse.
- [Mark] How far did you go in school?
- 11th grade.
- [Mark] And what kind
of work have you done?
- Just...
I'm sorry, it's just the stroke.
Done mostly self-employed work.
- [Mark] Okay.
Like construction, or...?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Stuff like that, handyman stuff?
And, and so you're married.
Do you have children?
- No.
- [Mark] No kids.
But you had, you got convicted
of, as a sex offender?
- Yes.
- [Mark] What year was that?
- 2010.
- [Mark] And tell me what happened.
- The, I had child pornography
on a computer
and they looked
at the, all, or the...
File-share programs,
LimeWire,
and they did a sting
of the people
that, that were on there.
- [Mark] And they found
that you were watching
child pornography?
- They saw that I had files.
- [Mark] How did they make
you aware of, of this, I mean,
they came to your house?
- They came to the house and,
and served with a warrant.
- [Mark] How did that
happen, that could just...?
- They came early in the morning
and basically just announced themselves
and served the warrant.
- [Mark] Must have been a big surprise
to you.
- I'm sorry?
- [Mark] Was that a big surprise to you?
- Yes, it was a surprise.
- [Mark] How much prison time
did you, did you do for that?
- I was in six,
six years in prison.
- [Mark] Six years.
- Six, six and a half years.
- [Mark] And after you got out,
this follows you, the record,
the conviction record
of, as a sex offender
is something you have to
register each six months?
- I have to register twice a year
and see a probation officer once a month.
- [Mark] Right, and does this affect your,
how does this affect your life?
Are you, are you,
you have to live in a
certain neighborhood, or...?
- Yes, I have the
restrictions of so many feet
from the schools, and...
- [Mark] Where do you think the interest
in that kind of pornography came from,
was there anything in your
childhood or anything like that
that may have caused it, or...?
- [Ed] I learned in a
class for sex offenders
that it stemmed from desensitizing myself
from regular porn.
- [Mark] Oh, so by viewing
regular porn, that became,
- [Ed] Desensitized to it.
- [Mark] so you needed
something more extreme?
- [Ed] Yes.
- [Mark] Mm, interesting.
And how has that arrest
and that conviction
affected your life now?
- [Ed] It's very embarrassing.
When I did try to get a job one time,
it was hard.
But on the average,
people don't know what I'm
charged with, you don't,
you don't know by walking in the store,
sitting next to somebody at
a restaurant, what they did.
So it,
it, it did affect my group
of friends that I had.
- [Mark] Did you lose some
friends because of this?
- I lost a lot of friends over that.
- [Mark] And how did your wife take it?
- She was
and is upset.
- [Mark] I would be, can't blame her.
- She stuck by me through
the whole incarceration
and she is living like she is,
on probation, like I am.
- [Mark] How is that?
It's because you...
- Where I have to live, that.
- [Mark] Oh, I see, so she's,
she is taking punishment as well,
which is 'cause of what you've done.
What's, what's the most
important lesson you've learned
in all of this?
- Well, of course, not to do anything
that is against the law,
but that how much that your
things that you do affect
so many people that
you don't even think of
when you're doing something stupid.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And what, what emotion
do you deal with most,
do you, are you angry over
this, are you embarrassed,
are you anxious or depressed?
- I am angry
at myself sometimes for even
allowing this to happen.
Of course, I'm embarrassed.
And I feel for the people
that were in the videos
now that I've learned and see
that their lives has changed
because of somebody doing that to them.
- [Mark] What's, what's the
most painful part for you?
- I'm sorry?
- [Mark] Well, what is
the most painful part of all this for you?
- I would have to say
disappointing my family.
- [Mark] Are you still in
contact with them, or...?
- I'm sorry?
- [Mark] Are you still
on good terms with your family?
- Yes.
- [Mark] You are.
And what, did you do therapy
or anything like that?
- I did therapy, yes.
- [Mark] And was that,
you found that helpful?
- Yes, very good.
- [Mark] How often would that happen?
- Once a week, and it took almost a year,
a little bit longer.
- [Mark] And what, what kind
of things would you get into
with therapy?
- We learned about how
and why we did the things that we did,
what triggers caused you
to do it,
stress,
or, you know, some of the
people in therapy has,
have had victims, some did not.
It's just, it's, it's
a lot of therapy for...
- [Mark] Yeah.
Has, has all this changed
your views on pornography?
- I'm sorry?
- [Mark] Has, has everything
you've gone through changed
your views on pornography?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How, how so?
- I...
I just learned that I don't need it.
I don't need, I don't need to see it.
And that's it.
- [Mark] Mmkay.
Well, Ed, thank you so
much for talking with me.
- Okay.
- [Mark] And I wish you
and your wife the best of luck.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.